Everyone could please take their seat
again.
Can everyone please take their seats?
All right,
so I would now like to introduce our
second speaker,
Dr.
Arthur Hansen.
Now when I was reading through is
through the accomplishments of Dr.
Hansen,
I have to admit that I was a little
intimidated.
One of the first questions that came to
my mind was what was he doing at my age?
Well,
the answer is selling 75,000
pins with a slogan on them that he came
up with.
Give Earth the chance.
Dr.
Arthur Hanson is an officer of the order
of Canada and distinguished fellow with
the International Institute for
Sustainable Development following his
term as president and CEO from 1991 to
98 he has worked with a number of
organizations around the world providing
initial guidance,
conducting research and advising on
innovation for sustainable development,
environment and economy relationships,
biodiversity,
oceans and international development.
Dr.
Hanson has a strong interest in linking
science to public policy and works
closely with government bodies in
Canada,
the United States and Asia.
On specifics on specific problems
related to environmental management and
mechanisms of accountability and
governance.
For sustainable development.
In recent years.
Much of his professional time has been
spent working in with China.
He initiated some of the largest
environmental capacity building efforts
currently underway in Indonesia,
simultaneously working with the
government,
ngos,
universities,
and the private sector.
Much of this effort has involved
establishing graduate degree programs
such as environmental law and
environmental studies.
He served two terms on Canada's national
round table on the environment and
economy and was Canada's ministerial
ocean ambassador with the Department of
fisheries and oceans and for years.
Dr.
Hanson served for 10 years as a member
of the Canadian Foundation for
Innovation and as a mentor in the
Trudeau Foundation.
He has provided advice to the office of
the auditor general of Canada since 1990
and has chaired various national and
international initiatives from 1978 to
1991 he was professor and director of
the school for Resource and
environmental studies at Dalhousie
University.
Dr.
Hanson holds a phd from the University
of Michigan in the field of fisheries,
ecology and natural resources and a
master's degree in zoology or fisheries
from the University of British Columbia.
Please join me in welcoming Dr.
Arthur Hansen.
[inaudible]
thank you very much.
When you were speaking earlier about how
much it should cost to come to the
lecture or whether you had mortgage your
house,
I have known people that have mortgaged
their houses for the emotions.
Um,
but I just want to tell you one little
story about this teaching on the
environment at the University of
Michigan,
which the opening session of it was,
eh,
had attracted 18,000
people to an auditorium and we had to
turn people away.
But we had a special secret deal with
the president of the university because
nobody got this place for free.
And I was a fundraiser for all of this.
And uh,
uh,
it was a big week long event that I
won't go into details on.
But the funny thing about it was one
night at home,
I get this phone call from a guy who I
didn't know and tall,
and he introduced himself and he said,
you know,
I think it is a,
he had read our perspectives,
which had been published in some books
and that,
and,
and he said,
I think it's a righteous at the
university,
wants you to chart,
wants to charge you $5,000
for one night.
And I explained to him,
all of the university said,
nobody,
but nobody gets this for free.
And,
uh,
you're no exceptions.
We've,
our group was called an act
environmental action now.
And so,
uh,
we were preparing to raise the money and
he said,
well,
I really like what you're doing.
I'm prepared to give you $5,000
to support it,
but I want you to go to the university
president and say my name,
and then say,
uh,
he would give $10,000
if the university agreed not to,
uh,
to,
charges 5,000
for the [inaudible].
So I phoned up the head of the
university development,
uh,
who is president for that.
And he immediately said,
oh,
he's,
he phoned you.
Yes,
please come and see the president
tomorrow.
And so I go and the president of the
University of Michigan,
it was a labor negotiator and lawyer,
I guess a very nice man.
But,
uh,
I walked into his office and I have this
kind of sheepish grin on his face.
I knew before he opened his mouth that
we'd won and it turned out this was one
of the biggest benefactors to the
university.
And in fact,
his,
uh,
his family on guy,
his wife's family owned a newspaper
chain running out of Chicago.
And apparently her mother didn't want to
give any money away.
Her father wanted to give money away.
So instead they gave it to the kids who
gave it to good causes,
like the University of Michigan.
And so we got our money.
But the funny thing about all those pins
and that and also the,
uh,
enough,
this spin,
but those things that they,
the funny thing about that was that the,
um,
university put a condition that we could
charge no more than 50 cents admission
to this events event.
So between selling the pins and the 50
cent admissions,
I was the financial finances,
uh,
chairman.
So everyday I would go around campus and
we had this great network of people that
were selling pins and selling tickets
for the event.
And I had a suitcase,
which I think we still have our own
little silver suitcase.
And there was a normal little suitcase,
wasn't too big because it was filled
with coins.
So every afternoon I would try and
casually walk across for fear of getting
robbed because it was
fairly close to a rough city in Detroit.
And I be trying to be casual and my arm
was beginning,
but
there was a Latin and I,
I just gave a talk last night at,
uh,
w Pearson College on the West Coast to
phd students from Royal Roads University
and needs very,
very bright and competent young people
that go into the baccalaureate program
and have the privilege of attending
Pearson College.
And so I tried to give them a talk on
leaders,
laggards in the rest of us.
And I've been thinking about that
already in what you're saying.
Uh,
Jordan,
because in the oceans area we deal with
leaders and there's lots of them and we
deal with lots of laggards who see the
world in very narrow sorts of ways.
And,
uh,
we also see the rest of us who are the
people in this room that you and me,
because we can't all be experts in the
oceans and I'm not expert on all sorts
of things.
I go out for a frequent kayak,
writes and talks with a guy who's a
physical oceanographer,
one of the best in the field that this
in Victoria.
And,
and uh,
you know,
he gets into discussions with me that I
have no idea what he's talking about.
And I try and
like 200 foot waves and things like this
and I just don't understand because it's
all
mathematical and it's all been said.
So we're all learners.
We're all people who want to do good,
but we have to deal with some people who
really have very strong vested interest
as well and who are,
it'd be happy to take the last fish out
of the,
see if they can put it into the money
from that into their pocket.
So I'm going to,
I thought,
first of all,
I think we should give a Jordan and
honorary something
in ocean studies,
the ocean
sciences.
But Ocean studies is different and we do
need psychologists and people with human
behavior understandings to bring the
message out about the oceans.
That's been one of the problems.
Scientists don't do a very good job even
though they're very good scientists and
some of them do fortunately.
And then there's people like Jacques
Cousteau and so forth and many others
like that and organizations,
uh,
that,
that really try hard.
Many of the big foundations,
conservation international,
a whole range of ocean oriented,
uh,
bodies and so forth.
But it's still not enough and it won't
be enough,
I think until people,
uh,
who actually have a lot of interest in
oceans but wa but still lack feel.
They lack the means to do things about
it.
And,
uh,
and I would include,
not the MPs and that are members of
parliament tend to understand the
oceans.
And some people say to me,
they turn,
if people,
some people in some places in Canada to
turn their backs in the oceans are more
interested in agriculture and the things
that happened on land.
And that's a strong feeling that people
have that uh,
our parliamentarians have not risen to
the challenge even though they've
signed,
the government has signed those things.
And one of the things that
differentiates us from Australia is that
the Australians generally,
they all live in the course is one
thing,
surf on it,
fish from it,
do everything near the water and,
and,
uh,
they actually have the strong political
will.
There's politicians there,
uh,
who have taken the oceans as a cause and
who are very powerful,
uh,
politicians.
That's helped a lot.
And I'll come to that later in the talk,
but I want to start off.
Um,
and I,
I've got a lot to say.
I'm going to try and say it as concisely
as I can in watch the clock.
So we'll have some time for discussion.
Um,
and I want to start generally looking at
the global situation and then I want to
home in on Canada because we as Canadian
sitting here and,
and maybe some students who are not from
Canada here.
Uh,
this is the country where you're trying
to understand right now how we do things
and that's very,
very important.
Uh,
I think we're going to learn a lot from
other countries.
Some of the Asian countries,
good and bad,
we'll learn that.
I've worked with,
have some very interesting models for
fisheries management.
China for example,
they say they laugh at our fisheries
models.
Let me tell you the,
and the,
and the LLC for example,
and they say,
we haven't got the money or the time to
be able to debate the finer points of
the models that you have.
What we do is we just stop all fishing
during the spawning season for about two
or three or four months.
I forget exactly what it is in the
summertime.
Oh.
And it isn't that they're doing it
perfectly,
but a lot of elements of that simple
mechanism worked for them.
Maybe sometimes we need simpler things
rather than the very involved debate
that goes on between the scientists,
the fishery scientists who tend to be
all concerned about fishing and
population dynamics.
People like myself that deal with
ecosystems and think about food chains
and think about habitat destruction and
so forth.
And,
and then others who take yet another
point of view,
which is the fisheries economist who
said they get the price rate,
uh,
individually transferable quotas and all
sorts of exotica that I think are often
useful.
But there is no simple answer.
So I'm going to be filling in the blanks
here that Jordan has left me plenty to
fill in.
Um,
and,
and I'm going to be focusing a lot on
habitat a lot on the ecosystem because
it's my belief that in addition to
worrying about fishing,
you have to worry about what's happening
to where fish live,
which is in the water feeding on things
that in that marvelous food chain there
was described there.
And,
and,
uh,
indeed,
if we don't take that into account in
our decision making about fisheries,
then we only know about a quarter of
what's really happening out there.
So I just want to remind us first of all
that,
uh,
it's fair to say that our planet is
about water and the water is saltwater.
Uh,
70% of the,
uh,
the earth's surface is covered by it.
We depend on every single person in this
planet,
whether or not they live in Afghanistan,
whether they live in British Columbia,
Canada,
or Indonesia or any of the other places.
Um,
we depend on a variety of ecological
services from the oceans.
I won't go into that right now.
Uh,
but it's very important to recognize
that.
Secondly,
it is a history book of the Earth.
We look at the sediments,
we know,
understand where we get our oxygen from
and so forth.
And it's complex,
but we can understand that.
And we also depend on that as we look
for the resources we explained.
Where do we find out about how anchovies
go up and down because of El Nino and La
Nina from the ocean sediments.
And we looked for the scales of the
sometimes essential meets there.
Sometimes they're not there.
Um,
and,
and our use sediments and so forth.
Well,
all that oil that we use is basically
from phytoplankton from the sea and
other sea creatures.
It.
So,
um,
we have to do understand that it's a
basis of natural wealth and of our
prosperity,
half the people in the planet live close
to the ocean and that is always going to
be the case.
Um,
their prosperity through trade,
through fishing,
through all sorts of different things we
know about it.
So the oceans government's trade
settlement patterns and it,
we now know and understand where they're
clearly,
it also governs climate and therefore
climate change.
But it's also the source of conflict,
calamity and crises.
And I don't like to talk about crises,
but I have to.
Uh,
and particularly in this talk,
people say the ocean is in crisis and I
think it's true,
frankly,
despite all what we said at the
beginning of your talk,
Jordan and I would like to think that
uh,
um,
things are nice out there on the
environment globally.
They're in a downhill turn for sure,
but there's a way of looking at crisis
that I think it's very important.
And I,
again,
I go back to some of the experiences
that has been a lot of time in China.
China doesn't like to talk about
barriers,
about not being able to do things and so
forth.
What they cautioned me and say,
look,
talk about crisis.
Yes.
If you wish,
we understand we face crisis for a long
time.
We face crises.
How do you turn crisis into opportunity?
And that's very important.
Chinese do that all the time.
Crisis to opportunity and they actually
do it often.
They're able to solve the crises and
they're better off open new
opportunities.
I talked about what I call [inaudible]
crisis to sustainability.
How do we turn these things into a
sustainable development pattern?
Not easy,
but not impossible.
And particularly when I'm talking with
an audience and includes people of the
next generation,
we're going to have to solve all the
messes and problems and open the new
opportunities that come with new
technologies,
etc.
Um,
I don't want to leave you with a message
of failure and a message of
impossibility.
It has to be a message of opportunity
and then a message of hope and so forth.
And I think we can apply that to the
ocean.
So some of the examples that I'm going
to present or things that seem to be
going better now than they were,
say 10 years or 20 years ago.
So please keep that in mind if it gets
too gross and just remember,
uh,
I'm basically an optimist and want to
see hope for the future and hope that
the people who carry the burden forward
and the institutions that I hope Finn
can become as at one of those can make
real contributions to that.
I'm looking at Youth Finn,
like that person over there and some of
the others that I met earlier this
afternoon.
I really am honored that I can be here
to
kick off what I hope will be a
successful effort on the part,
not just a view of t students but
students across the country.
Because we need,
we need this kind of support and
understanding and real action that can
come out of the bigger people who carry
challenges forward into the next
generation.
The reason I was speaking at Pearson and
happy to do so here's in college is that
I am going further and further down the
food chain.
Um,
I feel that,
uh,
we have to be working in a very
intelligent way and communicating with
people that are still in high schools,
junior high schools and elementary
schools so that they come into the,
the university world with an attitude of
responsibility to some extent,
but understanding particularly of things
where they can make a difference in the
years ahead.
So those are some preliminary,
the points.
Okay.
So now we get into the nasty stuff.
Ocean health and decline.
You're going to hear these things and
there's a new index and I've given a,
there's a lot of words in some of these
slides.
Don't even try and read them all,
listened to me,
but I'm just,
we're trying to take a videotape of this
and we're going to intersperse some of
the slides.
So I want a little bit more detail.
That's why I put it in here.
And also a ways that you can find this
information easily.
So there's this new thing that people
have been trying for some time to get an
integrated,
uh,
overview of ocean health.
And you can see it's not very good
overall in the world.
60 out of 100.
And if you go on the website,
you can find what each country,
uh,
where it's good and not good.
Interestingly,
Canada gets 70 out a hundred.
So,
um,
uh,
maybe we can a trumpet a success in some
areas,
but I would say that,
uh,
certainly I don't see things in great
shape right now in Canada in the same
way that Jordan,
uh,
an artist as well.
And so let's,
let's talk about health for just a
second.
Two quick examples.
Beautiful place,
a broken archipelago,
uh,
broaden archipelagos where,
Alexandra Morton and others,
uh,
feel that,
the cage salmon that are aquaculture
there are carrying an excessive parasite
load,
that the wild salmon coming down the
pink Simon for very remote rivers,
uh,
on the BC coast are picking up the
parasite load and dying off.
This is a big tussle between science and
citizen science.
Um,
and,
uh,
I must say it's not a resolved issue.
I'm kind of on Alexandra Morton side,
I think on this.
But in general,
the health of the oceans,
the health of ecosystems and what it
means to us,
uh,
brings it back right into economic
terms.
Now,
this is another big puzzle.
Uh,
this man who I spend a day with,
uh,
several years ago took this picture and
his doctor,
Peter Ross,
who's just lost this job because the
whole group of people and toxicology,
the deal with ocean toxicological issues
paid for often by people from other
countries like the United States or a,
and give us data that's absolutely
essential.
Um,
from monitoring different Adam mainly
seals,
but up and down the coast so you can see
where pollutants are coming across from
Asia because of they hit the northern
stuff.
You can find out the effects of drugs
and diseases that come out in their
sewage from cities like Vancouver.
And then if you go down towards,
um,
uh,
the southern part of what's now called
the sailor's sea puget sound where
they've been building naval ships and
you can find all that heavy metal issues
and so forth.
So,
you know,
I get a feeling for things.
So there was a network that he was
involved with,
um,
and they've all lost their job.
We don't seem to want that information
anymore.
So,
uh,
are we getting the right kind of
information on the health of the oceans?
And I would submit if,
if we don't have people like Peter Ross,
um,
then it's quite difficult to get that
information.
I should also add,
it's a hilarious working with him.
He goes,
I'd wearing a hockey helmet because
there's two ways that you get the seals
and you don't really want to be the
seal.
The seal is going to live,
but it's going to have a few scars after
he's been visited or she from Peter
Ross.
So the,
the one way he likes to do it,
as you quietly go up in your boat and
you,
uh,
put on your hockey helmet and then you
run like hell into the water and uh,
under the shore and grabbed the seal,
they have to be of a certain size and
they're standardized.
Uh,
if you're lucky you don't got your head
on the rocks,
slippery rocks with lots of LG.
The other way in which he doesn't want
to do it,
but it also works is that a,
the seal school in the water and then
you,
uh,
he's got a thin nylon net out set out
and the seals go into the nab,
their startle and,
and he tries to get the,
uh,
one or two sales and make sure that no
others are in there and you get about
five minutes before the steels that are
struggling and maybe withdrawn.
So,
but he has been very,
very good scientist and it pains me
greatly.
He'll do fine.
Whether that network can continue its
work properly is beyond me.
I don't see how it can,
health is also about people in
communities.
Um,
if you live on the west coast or on the
east coast,
this is a prime thing that people feel
the loss,
they feel the loss of livelihood,
the loss of integrity,
of work,
that they felt important over the years
as fishermen or various other ocean
related,
uh,
activities.
And whether it's in Prince Rupert,
in northern British Columbia or whether
it's,
uh,
in communities in the south shore of a
newfoundland or Nova Scotia.
Um,
this is this very serious issue and it's
one that we don't seem to do as good a
job in Canada as places like Norway,
uh,
and maybe Australia and handling.
Um,
and we can come back to that point,
a new line,
new livelihoods and merge Lunenburg a
school of sailing school.
That beautiful schooner,
um,
sea kayaking,
a summer thing we'll watching.
Um,
and interestingly if you were into music
folk festivals and the the folk festival
and part of it is held right on the uh,
on the seashore and boats come and go
like this beautiful big one in the
background in middle of the picture,
but this also calamity in the oceans and
calamity takes many forms.
Um,
the cyclone Nargis for example,
uh,
in,
in Burma where over almost 140,000
people were killed by terrible Maldives.
The prime spokes country for climate
change,
melt ice basically disappear with sea
level rise in that given amount of time.
And,
and then there's the insidious kinds of
things like ocean acidification,
and I won't go through this slide,
but just to say that oceans and climate
change are intimately related,
but don't get nearly as much attention
as the atmospheric side of things.
I happen to think that on both the
mitigation side and just the general
scientific knowledge base,
that the oceans are basically still
largely ignored compared to their
significance.
Then we go on to things,
and this is an area that I'm very
familiar with and this brings me to
tears sometimes.
There's an area of the world called the
Coral Triangle,
Indonesia,
Philippines,
parts of Malaysia and parts of Papua New
Guinea area.
And,
and this is the leading center for ocean
biodiversity in the world.
It's the thing that drove me first to
live in Indonesia was the fact that I
was working in the Caribbean on
something for my master's thesis.
And I realized that for every species of
this little crab that I was looking at,
there was a six or seven species and the
coral triangle area,
if you go to that area,
that reefs are being destroyed at an
incredible rate.
Partly it's stupidity,
it's greed,
it's market demand for certain things.
I could go on Fisher poisoned so he can
get maybe a 10th of them for aquarium,
fish,
salt water,
aquarium,
fish that's coming under control a bit.
People go off and risk their lives to
have in the last decades risk their
lives to go into old munitions dump,
uh,
dumps in,
west Papuan in Papua New Guinea to,
to uh,
take the explosives to take them out of
the shells and then go back and blow up
reese with them.
And I've seen these raves in some cases,
small islands for example,
in South Sulawesi where,
where the,
the very lives of people depend on the
integrity of the reef because they
protect the small islands around where
people live.
And still people will come in from
outside and blow off the reefs just to
get the fish done,
the fish,
take the fish goodbye,
go to another reef.
And the damage that's rigged and that
process is,
is quite incredible.
We'll come back to the coral triangle
because the countries now recognize
that,
that it's urgent.
That is a crisis situation and they're
trying their best to do a number of
things.
One of the,
one of the important points is that they
talk about a blue carbon budget.
In other words,
the reefs,
if they're properly managed and not will
extract a great deal of a greenhouse
gases as a consequence of the reef being
there and more or less do it
permanently.
So there's always good news and there's
lots of bad news,
West Africa,
uh,
the fishing the,
the term,
which I don't really like,
but it's a illegal unreported and it's
unsustainable as well.
But,
uh,
fishing.
Um,
and this is one of the prime areas that
is um,
um,
bringing people in from the surrounding
countries and taking fish,
cod,
taking fishing illegally.
And then these fish will be transported
office as a Korean vessel on the bottom.
So it will be transported to Korea I've
possibly through Europe,
uh,
and,
and some sold in theU as well on the
bottom.
Uh,
it's a,
a mothership with a illegal trawlers
that are out there and there's now
spotting mechanisms where the local
populations,
because as was already said,
people now have access to equipment like
this waterproof cameras and this,
that and the other access to the
internet to know exactly which chip it
is.
It's a fishing and people that go out in
their canoes and take pictures and then
report that.
So this was one of the interesting
things that technology can be very
helpful in this process.
And then finally I'm going to talk quite
a bit this evening about the Arctic
changing environment and development
pressures.
These are some photos I wish I had been
in a nice position to be able to fake.
These are taken by department of
fisheries and oceans staff,
but in our whales and um,
belugas coming up in the little areas
that are open in the Arctic.
Well,
we know there's going to be lots more
areas open in the future,
but we don't know what the fate of these
animals will be.
Now,
I did this diagram to try and understand
the overall governance of ocean use.
Um,
and I know a lot about that mainly
because I've worked with some very
interesting layers and others,
uh,
people involved with fisheries
management and [inaudible] management.
And don't worry about all the details I
find I did this diagram,
but the year 2000 hasn't really changed
much except that now there's a,
not just the 1992 Rio,
but as was pointed out,
we're up to 2012,
Rio plus 20.
Um,
and the,
the important point here is that
whatever we do with the oceans now
doesn't just involve Canada,
doesn't just involve a province in
Canada.
It involves international management,
the use of global consensus documents
like the law of the sea.
It involves trade in an investment,
a activities of various sorts.
And I'm going to talk about some of
these national and local interests,
which are often very vested interest and
not in the best interest of the ocean,
but sometimes they are and they're not
listened to and the generation of
knowledge,
uh,
which comes not just as knowledge from
scientists,
but it comes from people that have a
flame in their belly like we heard in
our last talk and,
uh,
people that are in native communities,
first nations community groups,
and many,
many other interests.
So knowledge now is drawn from many
places.
How do we put that knowledge together?
And so we have things like a very,
very,
very good thing called the global ocean
forum.
But don't have time to go into the AE,
but I suggest you take a look at it.
And this has become kind of a pressure
group at the international level.
And you can see,
don't worry about all of them,
but,
uh,
there's a lot of different areas and all
of these areas relate back to the
fundamentals of Aquatic Resource
Management,
fisheries.
There's also a new,
uh,
yet another I hasten to add and I don't
know what they're going to be able to
do.
A global ocean commission that's been
established launched just a few weeks
ago with a focus on the high seas.
Those areas of the deep blue that,
uh,
Jordan correctly pointed out are not
necessarily all the productive areas,
but they do play a major role still in
our use of the oceans.
And one of the big questions is what,
who should,
how should high seas,
uh,
marine protected areas be set up and how
should they be managed?
Because all those neat things like fin
tuna,
that goal in a big circle around from
the Gulf of Mexico up to east coast of
Canada,
across the West Africa and then across
it here.
And if they face a gauntlet of fisheries
boats,
a tremendous number of each of those
fishes worth $50,000.
One or two of those fish means the
difference for Canadian fishermen
between a good year and a bad year.
Uh,
and so the incentive to keep fee to have
sustainability of the harvest,
but there's also Japanese in the high
seas and those people in the
Mediterranean side,
et Cetera.
And there's a lot of,
some illegal fishing.
So anyways,
Paul Martin's a Canadian number of this
and I wish him luck,
but we frankly have had lots of very
good advice from global ocean
commissions and we haven't seen the
uptake of that advice nearly as strongly
as we should.
And that's a troubling,
uh,
matter.
So I'm entitled the,
uh,
Talk,
not just for the taking.
And I really mean that the oceans are
not just there for us to take.
We have to give,
we have to give a lot.
You have to give our best to make the
uses of the ocean sustainable.
We have to understand that other
creatures on this planet have a strong
rationale for being included in the list
of voters of the ocean and the people,
the creatures that have some take on
that,
a massive set of resources up there.
So,
but for us,
we at least can talk back and forth as
humans to each other.
Uh,
and,
uh,
we have to devise what I'd call a
responsible care approach for
candidates.
And so I'm going to go through some of
what I consider the elements of that to
be including some of the things that
directly relate to fisheries.
First question.
And this comes from,
uh,
John Fraser,
who I think a lot of former minister of
fisheries and oceans candidate who lives
in the west coast.
And he talks,
um,
as a person who is totally and
absolutely committed to the health and
the wellbeing of the oceans and says,
who speaks for the oceans and what are
they doing about it?
And I think that for your group,
Finn,
you should ask that question.
You should be one of the groups that
speaking for the oceans,
but what are you going to do about it?
What is it that you can do to make a
difference?
And that question should be first and
foremost in your mind.
Here's a couple of Canadian authors do
add to the very good list.
Uh,
and that was a short list by the way,
that,
uh,
Jordan,
mentioned there.
There's lots of others,
but the book's Seasick,
uh,
written by Ilana Mitchell,
former global mail writer.
She put a couple of years of her life
into writing this book and it's very,
very good and it's been highly
acclaimed.
In fact,
uh,
and it's based on science,
but she's not a scientist first and say
that she's a journalist trying to
explain things about the oceans and you
can see from our title of what her
conclusion is.
Uh,
Farley Mowat,
who's often a controversial figure,
but his book,
Sea of slaughter.
We'll go more detail about the things
that Jordan was talking about,
about this unending slaughter of
creatures from the ocean over the last
500 years in Canada.
Um,
I once showed a film about sea of
slaughter at Dalhousie University and
the graduate students that,
uh,
asked me to stop it in the middle and
they said,
we can't take anymore if this is what
the situation is.
Why are you spending your time on this?
Why don't you just give up and try and
do something simpler?
That's enough the way I'm constructed,
I guess.
But the point is,
it's not pleasant greeting,
but it's a reality check about what we
have done in the past.
And I'd also like to pay tribute to some
people who,
uh,
you know,
Canada as a nation has produced some of
the best fisheries and ocean scientists
in the world at one point in time.
We were probably with along with a few
European countries,
um,
having the best scientific journals and
so forth and paying the most attention
in terms of free access to the
information and,
and good research codes of ethics and
funding in,
in the ocean sciences.
And,
and uh,
I've only put three names up here of
people who are involved as an ocean
studies or ocean science,
uh,
people that have regrettably passed
away.
I,
if they were still alive and there's
many,
many of my colleagues that I could put
up here,
I'd be hard pressed to choose which
ones.
But let me just give you this very brief
profile of these people ran,
ran myers ransom,
Myers worked for the government and left
the government wanting to be more
independent,
became a leading.
I'm a professor at Dalhousie University
and got a great following from the
world's press because he told it like it
was using his accurate scientific
approaches as best he could about the
state of fisheries in various parts of
the world and including those in the
east coast of Canada.
Elizabeth Matador,
Gazer who many people worship around the
world and she is the daughter of Thomas
Mann,
the great author and a wonderful person
who gave herself over completely to the
oceans,
also at Dalhousie University,
but head at the International Oceans
Institute and trained and got the money
to train by hounding people like Bureau
Trudeau and others in Canada saying,
please give me money.
And then using that money to get more
money.
And so thousands of people now have been
trained in understanding the
complexities of oceans because of her
work.
She was also a great author,
uh,
on the oceans as well.
And the third person who died recently,
who I had the good fortune to work with,
who is a psychologist.
So not all is lost for you in this
field.
He sorted out how to,
um,
reduce the damage from the interaction
between fishermen and Wales and,
and,
uh,
Newfoundland that was his first claim to
fame.
Many more things since then.
But he learned how using basic
behavioral things that involve both the
behavior of the whales and the behavior
of the fishermen,
so that when whales got,
which is very frequent,
which when whales got caught in the
fisherman's traps,
we called traps.
Um,
the,
um,
and these are big whales,
really big whales.
And,
and everybody got upset at the Wales,
got upset enough from,
died fishermen put themselves in danger
but lost a great deal of money and who
wants to kill a whale?
So anyways,
he worked that out and had teams that
could actually go out and do it.
So,
uh,
but he did many more things.
Um,
and,
and these are people who made a
substantial contribution in their
lifetimes and serve as an inspiration
for me and for many others.
Um,
getting down,
and again,
I'm just suggesting maybe if you're
serious about wanting to understand what
we should be asking as research
questions,
here's what some of the nation
scientists in Canada and are talking
about,
and they bring,
they bring in these four areas.
Yes,
bray improve the fundamental scientific
understanding,
but we've got to have the information
about monitoring and how you use that
information and you have to look at
really understanding the impacts of
human activities.
And then you've got to bring this
information back into governance and
management.
So it isn't just about managing a
specific fish stock.
We've gone beyond that now because when
you try and do it,
we find often it's almost impossible
because there's big questions that,
that are ignored in that approach.
Um,
this is a rather interesting,
uh,
new,
and document this just come out,
but it gets to the,
what I'm going to try and say in some of
the things tonight.
Then there's other people that,
so there's this,
the scientific community speaks.
Then there's all these folks,
um,
uh,
see pause.
Canadian parks and wilderness society.
The Vancouver aquarium is a great place.
Uh,
ecology action center,
Nova Scotia,
the living ocean society in the west
coast,
wwf,
that major programs that relate back to
this.
And,
and I would really,
really strongly underlying first nations
and all three coast of Canada for coast,
if we include the maritimes,
we include the Great Lakes.
They have an incredibly important role
because they have constitutional rights
that relate back to the oceans.
So we have this opportunity,
we've got the longest coastline in the
world and our maritime estate people
don't often recognize is about,
uh,
depending on how you count it,
but it could be as high as 70% of the
land area.
So that's,
that's an important figure to remember.
And then we have this,
uh,
purple exclusive economic zone,
which from 1977 onwards has been the
opportunity side for Canada has been as
if we only had our hands on the
management of that.
And now we haven't had it for since
1977.
We could do much better,
get much more value from our use of the
ocean.
Uh,
we could make it much more sustainable.
Reality is sometimes been a little
different now.
Uh,
if you'll allow me a little bit of a
West Coast Navitas,
um,
from coast to coast to coast to coast.
So we started in Vancouver,
but the one I like here is just near my
home in Oak Bay,
Victoria,
um,
boxing day.
And you think of boxing day sales while
the people in and uh,
and uh,
Oak Bay,
think of sailing in a different sort of
way of boxing day and they are out and
the water in their wetsuits and their
boats with my baker in the background.
But here's another amazing thing.
The western Arctic,
um,
that ice highway goes 40 kilometers and
it comes up from the new vick.
You've traveled all along the Mackenzie
River,
and then you'd go to little hamlet of
Tuktoyaktuk,
which is important strategically for a
number of reasons.
And the last 40 kilometers you're
actually traveling on the Arctic Ocean,
the frozen ocean.
So they've just announced this week that
they are going to put in an all season
road,
which will be $300 million.
And of course,
one of the reasons for that is simply
that they won't be able to use ice
highways up there much longer.
This becomes a seasoned becomes too
short and tenuous.
Um,
and this was one of a person that I did
a lot of mentoring with Janell Kennedy,
uh,
on the eastern Arctic where of course
this is a primary or for what's going to
happen in the future with icebergs and
so forth.
Um,
but also one of the most interesting
areas,
um,
because we don't know very much about
the continental shelf and that area.
Some people say it's better known on the
surface of the moon than it is on the,
along the bottom of that area.
Um,
people are already looking at it though,
for oil and gas exploitation for
shipping purposes.
And they're also looking for,
I'm a fisheries surprising how many
things are happening in the Arctic right
now where people want to go up and test
fish and the east coast.
It's for things like cod and the west
coast.
There's already salmon moving around
into all of this at Pacific salmon are
now found in some Arctic rivers to the
other coast.
Gander.
I was in a narrow small airplane with
John Lean,
the person they will,
men Gander and Fogo island,
uh,
all covered in ice at that point.
And then to a place where,
uh,
I really enjoy being,
which is Lunenberg Nova Scotia,
one of the great shipping,
a wooden ship building and so forth,
uh,
basis.
And it happened to be there the day they
were relaunching the bluenose to um,
almost newly built.
And it's kind of interesting if you look
along that shoreline,
there is the sea shepherd,
you would know the sea shepherd,
Paul Watson's both,
which has been pounded by Canada,
um,
for,
for reasons that I won't explain it
right now.
And then you can see these other large
boats.
Um,
and you can see the dartmouth ferry and
the small naval vessel and dry dock
there as well.
It really is an active little spot,
but don't forget that the oceans
influence extends to uh,
Ontario,
not only directly through the New
Orleans region and particularly
therefore for Quebec,
but also the water comes out of Ontario,
the quality of the water and so forth.
Uh,
creatures from the ocean come up into
the Great Lakes,
uh,
including those El wives and some other
little things that are really nasty and
cost us billions of dollars in
management of these species.
But,
uh,
it's also officially considered in
Canada that these are inland seas that
deserve to fall under the purview of
fisheries and oceans for some things.
And then we think of the Gulf of Saint
Lawrence.
Now,
uh,
it's a very interesting body of water
there,
but what I'd like you to look at is
those little circles and then I'm going
to show you some more circles.
Um,
one of the most interesting things for
me,
I've tried to simplify my understanding,
a very complex oceanography is to look
at the things that go round and round
and dryers and circles of one sort or
another.
The simple example is when you go see
kayaking and you're out there straining
against the current and so forth,
maybe the tides against it and there's a
strong current and maybe a wind blowing
against you.
So you go in and shore and then you find
a countercurrent and then you're just
swept along because that countercurrent
is going this way while the main
currents going that way.
So you get a free ride instead of being
out at.
So lots of other things get free rides.
So if you look at what's called the
Haida Eddie here and see these little
swirls out in the going out into the
ocean there,
well they're driven by the fresh water,
which is all that red stuff coming down
from the rivers,
like the Skeena river and some others.
And,
and um,
those swirls are,
are driven by the current patterns of
the ocean and they go out and they
transport all the larvae from the
insurer and the nutrients out to the
offshore.
So you talked to Jordan about the,
the Simone's and one of these.
Now Boys,
Sema is just out there,
up near the top end of it.
Uh,
uh,
that second set of swirls off there.
And,
and uh,
um,
that's how it gets all the fish that,
that are out there that make it very
special and why it's a high productivity
area.
Another one is in the beaufort gyre up
in the Arctic and that's a collection
point for the whales in the Arctic and
some of the,
uh,
fish species as well because of the high
productivity,
same when the Gulf stream.
And here's a good example of how little
we understand.
For a long time the oceanographers
didn't understand that there were these
dryers and,
and that area of the Gulf stream.
So the Gulf stream is going off,
coming up the coast of the United States
and heading off to Europe.
And then there's all these counter
currents that are swirling around just
like the ones I'd be looking for on a
kayak.
And then they're warm water,
they're drinking warm water in off the
ocean.
So if these,
um,
countercurrent is happened to be in
place just at the time that the scallops
which are down on the Georges Bank shelf
are spawning,
then the little creatures coming up,
it gets swept away by the warm water
cause they're cold water creatures and,
and uh,
you don't get a good spa in that year.
So if you're going to try and understand
the management of things,
you have to understand phenomena like
the,
uh,
the gyrus and the eddies and the oceans.
And this is my first introduction here.
If things,
ecological,
physical,
ecological phenomena that that won't
come out through an examination of
studying fishing pressure cause their
environmental and focus.
And there's lots of those kinds of
things in the oceans.
So this is led to great tusks.
You can't believe,
it's just like among economists,
they,
you know,
it,
what's the saying that if you get a
three economists in the room,
you'll get four opinions,
you know,
or something like that.
And it was the same is true with a
fisheries biologist.
I've actually sat in the office of an
ecological,
uh,
ocean scientist in British Columbia.
I just happened to be there when he was,
uh,
this is after the cod disaster.
And he had just published a,
an article with some others in science
magazine,
very highly respected Journal saying
that the fisheries management people
basically didn't understand what they
were doing.
A,
which I agreed with him by the way.
And we were talking about that the phone
rings just at that moment from a fishery
scientist who I won't give the name of
an eastern Canada,
but who worked for government and who
was threatening to sue him for
defamation of character because they
had,
they were at odds,
uh,
they were analyzing the same problem
from entirely different points of view.
And particularly when I lived in Nova
Scotia,
I could give you endless stories of
this.
And,
and they,
they were,
uh,
in one case,
there was a whole very large ecosystem
group and they were shut down.
They were shut down by the higher ups
because they were producing data that
were at odds with what the population
dynamics people were producing.
I'm giving a simplified version of
things,
but,
so the point is,
um,
and I used to say this,
the students when I was teaching a
fisheries things,
and,
uh,
in a Nova Scotia,
don't trust the experts,
you know,
form your own opinions.
The experts are often very wrong and
they wear blinders just like everybody
else in society.
And one of the biggest ones is about
fisheries management.
Same could be said at times in the past
for forest management with fisheries
management is inherently even more
complex.
At least trees stand in line and can be
counted.
Rarely is that the case with fish.
Um,
because of water kearns money,
other things.
So here's,
here's just a little,
a collection of books,
a Nikah triple that collection about
these different points of view.
And I won't go into details now,
and this is a side story here.
Um,
this is in Lunenberg Nova Scotia.
And how many have ever been to
Lunanburg?
How many have ever been to Nova Scotia?
Great,
great.
Well,
if you go down to the Lunanburg,
you'll see that it's very moving,
very,
very moving.
Uh,
um,
uh,
set of,
what would you call these obelisks
maybe,
I guess,
and they list as much as possible the
names of people who were killed at sea.
In some cases there might be,
they don't have all the names because it
would be 50 or 100 people were killed in
1927.
Again,
while we were living there,
there was a terrible incident,
but these are just people from Lunenburg
area cause this was the grand banks
fisheries and um,
and it's very moving to see it.
But the point is,
uh,
we remember a lot about our ocean passed
and we even tend to glorify it or feel
sad about it or whatever.
But what have we actually learned,
you know,
and there's a just a little window
dressing.
There is couple of postage stamps to
remind us about the glorious past.
And that's the,
I'm a fellow on the right.
Uh,
Angus Walters was a very famous captain
of the fastest of the,
uh,
of the ships,
the bluenose Newfoundland.
That's that abundant cod population.
But the interesting thing is the man
that told us early on stuff let is still
being quoted,
is Harold in this,
uh,
from the University of Toronto,
who was an economist who dealt with this
idea of heartland and hinterland in
Canada.
And the fact that we were hewers of wood
drawers of water for traders,
but also,
uh,
we dipped into the emotion and he wrote
this,
what happens when you get a really,
truly abundant resource like the cod
fishery?
So that's,
uh,
that's his book written in 1940,
very prescient.
And basically he's saying as a,
uh,
an abundant tradable resource can fuel
and economy,
but it also traps you in many ways.
And,
and that is what has happened in Canada
in a sense.
We've,
we've relied on super abundant natural
resources,
not just fish,
but,
but it,
it allows us,
I thought a lot about this over the
years,
trying to understand why we behave
towards the resources we do.
Like for example,
with a cod,
when we lived in Nova Scotia,
you know,
he'd go in and buy this fish.
There was awful,
uh,
in the stores.
You couldn't get good cod in the stores.
And the reason it wasn't good was
because it was mishandled,
right from the time it was,
it wasn't nice,
it wasn't bled.
So you'd have a nice open flesh and uh,
it,
it was treated as if it was going off
the care where else,
uh,
to be treated a salted cod,
you know,
low value commodity.
Uh,
some other people,
Icelanders,
Norwegians and some others didn't do
that.
They treated the fish property,
they got a very good value added and
they started respecting the resource
base even more.
So that's the important thing for those
with an economic bent to recognize is
that you can,
one of the,
one of the ways in which we can actually
get more out of our resource get is to
add value to it,
handle it carefully,
respect each fish that we catch,
which gets again into why is it that we
can go in and use trawlers and take that
small fraction of the fish.
But anyways,
a lot of this stuff goes back to harold
in us.
And now the other thing is,
and I hear I differ a bit from what,
uh,
what was said about the,
the empty oceans.
Yes,
the oceans are empty because we've,
we've knocked out a lot of the food
chain,
but there still can be an abundance.
And as you correctly pointed out,
uh,
Jordan,
if you like eating a jellyfish,
which I actually,
I do there and I keep asking my Chinese
colleagues,
uh,
well why is it that you eat a chicken
feed or certain other things with some
of the certain other things?
Well,
it doesn't for the taste,
particularly,
it's for the crunch and crunch feller
and jellyfishes one of those things.
And the same with Indonesians and
others.
They liked the crunch and they're
delicious.
Now they're dried in Newfoundland.
Newfoundland couldn't believe it's good
luck when they discovered the,
were actually people in the world that
want to do eat jellyfish,
but uh,
they,
so they started drying them and
exporting them into at least a little
flat patties,
you know.
But there's certain other things that I
could mention as well.
And Squid.
Uh,
of course it's one of them.
And so what you find is a notion that
gets,
um,
very abundant in those creatures that
can be low on the food chain often and
what we call it,
the tritus food chains.
You know,
the stuff that rains down into the water
column.
So lots of fishermen are now happy to
see no cod and Nova and a,
well now I don't know about Nova Scotia
so much,
but certainly,
whoops,
everything shut off of a,
I guess if you've got it still,
you know,
you have,
can I ask some technical help up here?
Like I've got nothing on my screen and
then really like seeing the screen.
Oh,
it's okay.
Okay.
Talk to her.
It's just okay.
And then how do I get it to go back
here?
Okay.
So,
so we now have very,
very valuable snow crowd in northern
shrimp and basically the ecosystem has
changed.
Don't expect the car to come back unless
something catastrophic happens to these
guys because these are replaced,
basically replaced the card.
We'll see card for sure.
We'll see some other groundfish,
but we probably won't see them in the
abundance because these guys are eating.
And the food train now.
So,
but,
uh,
that's not necessarily a bad thing,
you know,
that there's fewer card if you're asked
the fishermen.
A lot of them have made it a lot of
money off.
These new species will say,
hey,
we're making more money,
we've got better votes,
et Cetera.
The question is,
and I've tried to look at this question,
but some people,
the auditor general's office,
uh,
some years ago and we concluded that
there was no knowledge base to support
the hypothesis that these actually were
being sustainably harvest and the new
ones.
In other words,
we might end up with the same problem,
but let's go back again to what a,
another thing that was mentioned earlier
and that is electronic gear and so
forth.
Well,
it's not exactly new,
but it's in this period from about 1970
on,
um,
and this man got a,
an honorary doctorate from I think the
University of New Brunswick.
Um,
and this oddly enough was one of his
boats,
which I have in the sea and the dry dock
in Lunenburg.
Um,
and,
uh,
Captain Medford Matthews was a real
innovator with gear.
And he brought in and saw,
this wasn't the first trawler that came
by any means into the region.
Uh,
but it's,
it's kind of like the early brand of
the,
of the,
uh,
trawlers that are of a modern type and
well equipped with all the gear that can
take a lot of fish soner things and
other equipment.
Well,
here's what they look like.
No,
here's another one with a couple of
kayakers for scale.
And these things are essentially the
bulldozers of the sea.
They,
they,
they do so much damage to the bottom.
They rip things up and I think
eventually probably will see these
things phased out for other types of
gear.
That's my hypothesis.
But in the interim,
these are deadly machines for from the
point of view of what they can hold for
fish.
It doesn't mean that they can't be made
to be useful contributors towards
sustainability if they're held in check.
But,
um,
particularly when you get in these big
vessels and then you'd get a facilities
on them or factory boats that can
accompany them,
that can take an immense amount and stay
at sea for long periods of time because
they can devastate a whole region of the
ocean very quickly.
Now,
then we move to what happens to fish
after it gets caught.
Um,
if you look at this plant at the top,
national seafoods,
uh,
is the worlds one of the world's major,
a fishing companies.
Uh,
and one of the largest ones in candidate
this plant located in Lunanburg was the
world's largest fish plant in the 1980s.
Now,
my daughter Laura,
will quite well remember when we used to
go down to the cottage some days we were
down in window of this,
uh,
this,
a plant and it was just a bad smell and
they were taking all the remains of
making,
cooking it to make it into fish meal and
selling it.
But what does national seafood do now?
Um,
white fleshed fish such as cod,
haddock,
pollack,
and a bunch of others are kind of what
some people in the banking business
would call fungible.
I either all you can exchange them
interchangeably.
Uh,
they're white flash,
we can make them a deficient chips.
You can even take something like
Tilapia,
uh,
which is a freshwater fish and call it
cod.
And that happens sometimes illegally,
but it happens.
So in today's market supply chain,
because China has become the most
efficient processor,
they get all this fish go into China and
it goes through big ports like Rotterdam
where it gets all muddled up.
It could come from west Africa,
it could come from southern America,
whatever gets turned into chunks of fish
that are partially processed there.
Then it comes back to companies like the
one in Lunanburg where people squirt
some nice things on top of it and maybe
make it a little fancier and make it
into a frozen dinner or something like
that.
Then it gets step made in Canada and
then sent to the United States are
consumed in Canada or maybe in Europe
even.
Uh,
so that's,
that's a reality.
So if you were listening to the radio
and the last few weeks,
there's been a release of a report that
estimates that something like 30% of
this fish is actually mislabeled because
once it gets to Rotterdam or wherever,
you don't know whether it's a card or
whatever it happens to be.
So market supply chains go through this
complex thing and um,
it makes it very difficult for us to
know a,
whether we're really eating what we
think is caught or whatever else it
might be.
B,
whether it was caught sustainably,
uh,
or even whether it went through some
mission happen.
It's a,
and it's a process that lowered the
quality of the fish.
So this has become a major,
major problem,
uh,
in,
ocean management and in management of
the seafood chains,
the sort of thing that you're talking
about.
If you want to be a good citizen and
only eats sustainably produced fish.
Fortunately,
there are solutions.
Um,
but just to give you another example of
this,
uh,
and this is an area where Australia was
furious with us.
See these,
this large fish,
the Patagonian toothfish,
which some of you may have eaten us.
How many people,
and I shouldn't ask the question,
but if you want to raise your hand,
have you ever eaten Chilean Sea Bass?
Okay,
well,
Chilean sea bass is one of those fancy
names that's given for something that's
actually a fish coming from Antarctica.
And for the most part unsustainably
produced.
And at one point in time,
this has been cleaned up quite a bit
now,
but it was going from Antarctica,
uh,
an pretty much an unregulated fishery.
Uh,
even though the Australians were really
making a pitch for it and,
and then he would go to China,
it would be handled there,
then it would come to Canada and then
it'd be try and shipped to the United
States as Canadian fish.
Australians weren't very happy about
that.
I can tell you.
Uh,
but,
but again,
this just illustrates things.
So one of the ways to get around us is
through all these various choices that
you can make and people that help you to
make good choices.
It started with the Monterey Bay
aquarium and now the Vancouver aquarium
is in their seafood watch.
Uh,
the most critical thing is something
started by wwf and some others in the
private sector,
uh,
on the,
what's called the Marine Stewardship
Council,
which is now certifying some,
some species of fish and interestingly
many chefs now in the world will refuse
even in countries and places like Hong
Kong and some of the big hotels,
they will refuse to handle fish that are
not certified.
And this is a real step forward and I
could tell you some interesting stories,
but I'd better move on.
So just go to a fish choice.com
and take a look at some of the things
that are on there or any of these
individual websites.
This is the future.
This is a future that responsible
seafood companies like national see,
see us,
what they would be faced with.
All of us and countries like China are
now starting to recognize that they will
have to become involved.
Then there are some of the really nasty
things like a shark's fin.
I took this picture in a Chinese
restaurant.
But the interesting thing there is,
um,
[inaudible] the guy who was so,
so tall,
and he reaches to this guy,
a basketball player from China and
respected,
highly respected within China and a
person who doesn't just play basketball,
but he's very interested in public
policy issues.
And,
and he came out and said,
I will not have my wife to be and I will
not have,
um,
shark fin soup served as it's
traditionally done at Chinese weddings.
And I'm going to encourage all my fellow
basketball players in sports figures and
so forth to do the same.
He's probably had more impact than any
other single thing of the scientists and
others who bring their hands because
China is a primary place now for shark
fin soup and where all those 70 million
or more shark fins are going now.
Little known facts,
I think the facts,
but it's always interested me in Nova
Scotia that there's been a sort of
fishery.
And if you go back far enough,
there was a,
there was all sorts of books written by
people,
I think Zane gray type of books.
Um,
very rich people used to go to Nova
Scotia and,
and catch them off as a sport fishery.
But in the 1940s,
still even,
uh,
there was,
um,
a harpoon sort fishery in glace bay up
in Cape Breton Island,
hundreds and hundreds of boats.
This is just one picture from the,
um,
from the era.
And they had these canoes that they went
out in and men would go out there with
Harpoon waiting to catch up 400 or more
phone swordfish.
The interesting point about it is it
still exists,
and one of the points right now is that
the marine stewardship council has been
asked to certify harpooned fisheries in
the United States and in Canada.
Um,
and then also the pelagic longline.
Now you've got introduced to the long
line and,
and some people wrap their hands to put
their hands to their heart and say,
the long line is the way to go because
it's not involving those trawlers.
But with the long line does is catches
turtles,
sharks and all sorts of other things
that are not the ones that species,
um,
at the same time as they're catching
swordfish.
Uh,
but,
uh,
controversially,
the Marine Stewardship Council has
awarded the Northwest Atlantic Canadians
sort of fishery,
which amongst about $10 million a year,
um,
certification that they were doing it
properly.
Uh,
I'm not so sure.
I don't know now this one.
But the interesting thing is that
already awarded the spirit fishery for
the,
sorry,
the yes,
the spear of fishery for the swordfish
re,
uh,
they're still using spirits out there.
And if you go,
if you're google something along those
lines,
you can actually see little things for
sportsmen in the United States.
For example,
going out and votes and throwing this or
harpoons at getting swordfish.
But you can see what happens that uh,
the government in the late nineties
really put a clamp on things cause you
could see the decline on the,
on the sort of fish going down there and
what below what is considered a maximum
sustainable yield of biomass.
And you can see as the consequences of
stopping that fishery,
how it's built up to the point now where
they feel that they can re-institute
illimited sort of fishery.
So these are the sorts of things.
This is,
this is an odd ball little example.
It's not one of the great fisheries,
but there's dozens,
even hundreds of these other kinds of
fisheries out there that don't get the
same kind of presses.
They cod fishery.
Uh,
the big ones.
the biggest single thing we have going
for us now is the lobster and then had
a,
uh,
is a ground fish that is still retaining
some place in the and the scale of
things.
A very nice fish to eat.
But these are the things that sustain
the small communities in the social
work,
Nova Scotia,
Bay of fundy and so forth.
But the point here is that the haddock
went down and it went down maybe because
of what we're fishing,
but it wasn't on the scale of over
fishing of the,
uh,
of the card and almost certainly water
temperature has played a role in it.
So again,
what's cause and effect between fishing
pressure and uh,
fish abundance?
Sometimes not very clear.
Here's another one.
This just,
uh,
a friend of mine took this picture last
weekend or the weekend before,
one day a fishery and you get all these
collections of boats going out and,
and they kill immensely.
They take huge schools of herring and
then the goals and other birds are
there,
eagles,
et cetera.
And the point here though is that the
abundance of herring is that the
greatest level in the last 30 to 40
years,
responsible fishery scientist would say,
we have no idea of why they would make
claim credit to and sales because our
careful management,
but it's been up and down and up and
down.
There's,
I,
you don't have time.
It was an awful lot of interesting
stories about this fishery and about the
way the native people,
the first nations along the coast
perceive how it should be managed,
where they wouldn't have any of these
bullets up there.
They would be,
because it's mainly managed for herring
row,
you know,
they eggs and,
and uh,
they go to Japan and places like that.
But,
um,
they would manage by lifting the things
out on of Kelp where they'd been spawned
by the official themselves and get rid
of the bullets period.
So there's different points of view of
what you can do and some of those things
I think are going to be the things for
the future.
Salmon.
I have spent a lot of my life looking at
reading about,
trying to understand Simon.
I'll be the first to say it's really
difficult,
not the only person to say that.
Um,
there's aboriginal interests which are
strongly constitutionally supportive
commercial interests,
which often are on the decline sports
fisheries interests,
which claim to produce about five to 16
times the value per fish landed because
fishermen spent a lot of money.
Uh,
and then there's agriculture and
anybody,
anybody here from BC?
Great.
Well,
you know that this is not exactly an
easy subject in British Columbia.
I mean,
everybody has an opinion on it and,
and uh,
it's really difficult.
But look at this.
This is a plot,
uh,
several years ago of watersheds and
counter because you have to involve the
freshwater watersheds in British
Columbia.
I should say we're sockeye salmon is in
decline.
So the yellow and red watersheds,
huge watershed is under threat.
That's likely to,
uh,
increase,
because of global warming and the
streams are warming up and other things
happening in the watersheds.
The Pine Bark Beetle killing all the
trees,
trees go and water runs off,
isn't there for the spawning season.
So the salmon's truly in trouble no
matter what aquaculture.
Uh,
if you're looking at a,
a net like this,
this is a fairly well run,
uh,
agriculture,
setting in a,
on each of those netted areas holds
about 50,000
fish this size.
And if you've ever seen anything like
that close up,
it's quite amazing.
So this is just fish pack in place.
The fish aren't discontented.
Um,
and,
um,
you know,
there's varying points of view about it,
but some of you may know that,
uh,
our prime minister appointed,
justice from British Columbia who was
called the Koan commission to look at
the future of the Fraser River Salmon,
the biggest bear run.
And,
and,
uh,
don't read all of this,
but the basic point is that a Cohen
said,
if,
if people were expecting that,
I'd find a smoking gun one causality to
it.
No,
no way.
And I think I certainly felt that would
be what he would come up with at the
end.
But there's all sorts of factors,
but read what he says.
Fraser River sockeye face and uncertain
future shrinking resources,
um,
which may result in delays in
implementing reforms and research as
shrinking,
shrinking resources,
being less money around dfo has been cut
badly.
Um,
meaning that the stressors to with
Sockeye are exposed will continue and
the deterioration of sockeye habitat
will get worse.
The water's constituting Fraser River
sockeye habitat or warming.
And then pointing out that basically
because the government had taken a bunch
of amendments before receiving as a,
to the fisheries act that uh,
in fact the future of management of the
Fraser River is unknown and that's
putting it in the most positive terms.
And,
and so,
um,
these are guarded comments,
the whole report,
the summary of that,
if you want to get a sense of that
particular very important resource and
why it's difficult to manage,
read that report.
So my,
my,
uh,
concern.
So we have these various things that we
can do in Canada for the oceans and two
big things.
What is the Fisheries Act,
which was in,
uh,
is in a very old,
one of the first pieces of legislation
we had encountered.
And I won't give you a ball boring and
dull description of all the parts of it,
but it sets the basis for conservation
of fish for pollution control and a
number of other things related to
habitat,
etc.
And also sovereignty over our resource
and sovereignty between the federal
government and provincial governments
and,
and its management.
Uh,
it's a very important piece of
legislation.
It's been changed quite dramatically in
the last year.
Placing less emphasis on the habitat
aspect in particular.
Uh,
but we also have the oceans act in
Canada and this was a new piece of
legislation that came out in the 1990s
and essentially set a new basis of
management around ecosystems,
sustainable development in another
words,
balancing between the various kinds of
uses of the ocean and specified the need
for attention to marine protected areas.
And also,
uh,
what was called la eventually became
called wool,
most large ocean management areas to
take big chunks of the ocean and try and
develop,
uh,
plans for them.
I'm just going to give you a very brief
overview of a few of these and you can,
uh,
th this talk will be available to
anybody that wants it and you can see in
more detail but,
but the Lomas,
uh,
represent,
move towards the ecosystem based
approach and one that's based on
consultation among the various users,
whether they're first nations,
whether they're oil and gas,
fisheries and so forth.
It's building relationships and dialogue
among the various users.
And the idea is to plan for surprises,
plan for management strategies that you
could actually implement and get that
information in advance of development.
So a one that I'm very familiar with is
eastern east coast Scotian shelf and
they produce good work,
um,
and so forth.
I won't talk about it anymore.
One that's citizen led,
uh,
scientists led and led by both Canada
and the United States is the area of the
Gulf of Maine,
particularly Georges Bank.
As part of that.
And then happened to the Bay of Fundy
and a here,
the federal government has a limited,
it has taken a limited rural,
um,
and it's been the states and the
provinces working together.
That's really done some very innovative
work.
Won't have time to go into it.
But I wanted to say just one thing,
if you take this is the boundary line
between the two countries.
Uh,
painfully worked out.
And I can tell you interesting stories
about that cause I was at some level and
some of that,
it was very interesting.
But if you look up towards the Bay of
fundy and into north towards New
Brunswick,
which is,
uh,
just to the right at the top of the
line,
top line,
um,
whales and ships collide up there
because that's where it's a natural,
one of these areas with lots of
occurrence flowing and dryers and so
forth.
And it's incredibly productive.
The whales come up there to feed in the
summer.
Some of the scarcest whales,
humpbacks are there,
but some of the other whales and they
collide with the ships.
So you get these ships going up into,
um,
particularly for an oil refinery located
up there and they find a whale draped
over this.
They have a kind of a bulbous front on
them and there was a whale of dead whale
there.
And,
and so the right whales particularly,
um,
there's only about 300 of them left,
I think,
and they were being knocked off right,
left,
no pun intended,
uh,
in that area.
So there was a simple solution.
It was a very simple solution.
And one that's worked remarkably well.
They just changed the shipping lanes
slightly and they put in place a kind of
a spotting mechanism cause you can see
the whales and so people would know
where the whales tended to be clustered
on a given day.
So there's some leeway in where the
ships go and problem not completely
solve,
but let's say 80% salt.
So there's,
there's,
there really are win win situations out
there.
And the charge for that was led by,
you can see how Nova Scotia goes down to
kind of a little point,
not,
not the big part of Nova Scotia,
but there's a little kind of peninsula
and beautiful place.
Now the school teacher was living out
there and she took it upon herself to be
part of the solution and organize local
groups to actually spot and be able to
say where the whales would be and
demonstrated to the scientists who
didn't really believe in this.
I don't think very strongly that,
that it could actually be a solution.
So it started from a citizen and I have
a lot of respect for what I see is
citizen science in the oceans,
uh,
throughout this country.
I could give you many other examples in
the west coast,
in the Arctic and so forth.
Another one that I think involves a
heavy degree of citizen input is the
same,
the Gulf of Saint Lawrence,
uh,
action plan,
which is being implemented primarily
through a,
um,
a environment Canada.
And here there's something called Zip.
We don't need to go into the details of
it,
but zip committees exist throughout the
golf,
in and around particularly around go
back.
It's all just all of life.
Um,
and the,
the neat thing about it is that a,
it brings the stakeholders together and
they come to real solutions about local
problems that affect their part of the
Gulf of Saint Lawrence.
And the government and others provide a
broader input into overall what the St
Lawrence Action Plan would look like.
So there's some degree of coherence
throughout the whole region.
Now these are good things that are
happening and they've,
they,
they've been developed by people working
together,
painstakingly working together.
I might add for more than a decade of
interaction,
overcoming all sorts of obstacles or
differing points of view,
narrow points of view,
et cetera.
So these are some of the good things
that are happening in Canada.
Uh,
one that I helped to get underway in
terms of some of,
I won't go into all sorts of stories
about it for time reasons,
but a terrible name,
Penn Sema Pacific North Coast integrated
management area.
And this includes,
um,
when I,
I hate the word also worldclass the
phrase world class,
but the oceans in this area are stunning
in terms of the diversity of life,
uh,
and also the intactness of the
ecosystems in this whole area in the
northern part of Vancouver Island.
Um,
up to Prince Rupert,
there's only 15 or 20,000
people living in that whole area.
And that's an area that's probably about
as long as the cost of much of the coast
of Norway.
For example,
I'm absolutely fine,
intact ecosystems.
You can fly at a reasonably low levels
and see gigantic sunfish floating on
their side into the weigh a thousand
pounds or more.
You can see whales,
you can see if you're in a boat where
the seabirds go.
And then there's important,
uh,
fisheries activities in that as well.
There's a wonderful atlas of it.
Uh,
if you want to look at it online and you
can download that,
but,
um,
there's all sorts of other activities.
This is drawn from that atlas just
showing who's got,
uh,
oil and gas exploratory wells and
tenures in the area.
Um,
uh,
you know,
all sorts of people have staked that
territory.
There's another one that shows,
uh,
all sorts of different fisheries
interests.
Well,
interspersed with those,
I don't know if I've got the,
no,
I don't.
Um,
I took it out for time reasons.
Uh,
if I,
if I could show you where the corals are
and where there's the thing called a
glass sponges,
which we thought were creatures that had
gone extinct.
They were studying as fossils in Germany
and that was where they found the
veranda.
The areas I think that are fossilized
now in Germany and suddenly about 15
years ago,
somebody discovered that there was huge
beds of these things around this area.
They're primarily in the area that's
kind of a pale orange.
Um,
so what are you going to do about it?
These were areas that were just
beginning to be used heavily by
trawlers.
The trawlers were starting to plow right
through these ancient beds because these
are,
some of these are thousands of years
old.
Um,
and,
and uh,
uh,
stock was put to it.
Um,
and now they're all applauded.
We know where they are.
There's an exclusion zones for the
corals for the,
a,
a fisheries in the same,
uh,
Iran up till about 2000,
there was an official almost denial that
there was a,
the soft corals that were found on the
east coast and the fishermen had been
complaining about a particularly long
liners that the trawlers were going
through and bringing up these things.
And I went to a Fisher Fishery
Association for museum and Southwest
Nova Scotia and the handle these big
corals and if you went on the west coast
to do some of the commercial,
but um,
sports fishing shops and boats,
uh,
places they'd have them on the wall.
The same thing on the west coast.
Well,
officially they didn't exist and finally
they did exist.
And now there's all sorts of
exclusionary is for the red corals as
well.
So progress but it's slow and it's
painful.
The northern gateway,
I'm not going to even touch tonight if
you want to ask me questions about it,
but this is the prime example now of why
we need something like Benzema to
generate the kind of data that would be
helpful to know how much,
uh,
what is their actual risk.
Unfortunately,
for whatever reason,
the government has decided to more or
less,
not totally,
but more or less,
um,
got the cooperation that had been
established hoop and Sema and,
and that mechanism it seems to be lost.
Now,
another one in the north is the Beaufort
Sea partnership,
uh,
in which is a complicated thing and you
can see the vision of it is basically a
ecosystem health and supporting
sustainable communities and economies
for future generations as well as the
present.
The problem with the Beaufort Sea
partnership is there's a lot of things
that relate to land claims and,
and uh,
uh,
northern,
um,
local peoples up there that have made it
very difficult.
And I'm not blaming them,
but it's just there's a lot of obstacles
in the way still to make this move as
fast as it should.
Another one where another mechanism is
in place now and we're starting to get
in places lancaster sound,
lancaster sound,
who is one of the first places where
there were see use planning in Canada.
And at that time that was in the 1980s.
People were kind of looking at it as a
bit of a curiosity.
Now this is a very important part of the
northwest passage that will become one
of the areas used for shipping
eventually.
There's a large part of that has now
proposed as a national conservation area
and,
and uh,
this,
it'll be very interesting to see what
this will actually mean in reality.
Now I want to point out the,
the national marine conservation area
because we actually have legislation
saying that all the representative areas
in Canada,
there's 26 or 27 of them,
something like that.
Each of those kinds of habitats should
have representative areas where you
could actually pinpoint and say,
Aha,
this is,
this area is protected within that.
And it will tell us about the area.
I could be abused for fisheries
management and so forth.
Uh,
helping to replenish their stocks,
uh,
were far from there.
Just to highlight again what Jordan was
saying.
Ah,
look at the small percentage of
protected areas in the oceans in Canada
compared to the line.
And most people would say on the land
areas,
it's not enough.
So I don't look at the detail of this,
but these shows all these different
types of areas.
You know,
you can look at Hudson Bay for example,
or the north and south part of west
coast,
Pacific coast.
There's a lot of areas,
but particularly in the Arctic,
um,
we,
we need a lot more effort.
And one of the things that a c pause,
which has been a prime,
a contributor to this,
they have a whole list of things that
they feel are urgent priorities for
marine protected areas.
And they're not all being acted on at
this point in time.
So we do have a document and talk,
talk,
talk.
It's very cheap called the national
network of Mbas.
Do we have a national network of Mbas in
Canada?
Uh,
well here's one point of view from a
person who I respect a lot through the
Pew Foundation.
Daniel Pauly from UBC fishery center is
one of the people that really
understands the oceans and fisheries
very well in Canada and around the
world.
And,
uh,
he's been running something,
a database called MPA global,
looking at marine protected areas all
around the world.
And then if you go and look at the
Canadian entries,
there's 574 of them,
including provincial coastal parks and
ecological reserves and so forth.
I can go out in my kayak and go right
around the ecological reserves,
two kilometers off shore from where I
live,
uh,
for birds,
for example,
rain parks in British Columbia,
there's dozens of them.
Uh,
but they're mainly for,
they've been chosen not for their
ecological value,
although sometimes there is ecological
value,
but it's nice safe shelters for boats
that go up and down the coast,
you know,
small,
pleasurable.
It's a big pleasure bullets.
So,
um,
this is kind of overstates the case,
but it's not Daniel polly's fault.
This is following certain criteria.
Um,
we're starting to see this now emerge as
networks within the regions.
So for example,
um,
there's whale sanctuaries,
coral sanctuaries,
and a place called the gully where a lot
of the really interesting whales that
are off shore from Nova Scotia collect
now and then there's a lot of actually
land based ones so that you're primarily
for birds and protection of wetlands.
The problem with this is can you really
call it a network?
What are the criteria?
What,
how will it relate?
How will all of this relate,
uh,
that I've got on this diagram?
How will it relate to sustainable
fisheries management?
Because that's the kind of question that
we should be asking.
I don't think we're asking that question
very well and Canada now,
but I would urge fin to be thinking
about that when you're thinking about
sustainability of seafood and so forth,
how does it relate back to the other
things in the ocean ecosystem and how
can we use those tools better?
Uh,
Penn Sema,
this diagram shows the,
all these different places that I
mentioned,
the corals and other areas that deserve
some sort of,
um,
protection of one sort or another from
here and now.
Um,
management issues,
things like the trawlers and other
activities,
oil and gas in some cases.
Now here is the makings of at least a
west coast northwest coast network.
Here's what I'd like to see.
Uh,
if you look at Penn seem,
and I've taken it up to the 200 miles on
it because I feel we should be going out
to the 200 miles on this,
but if you had a,
I call it boy to brooks.
Brooks peninsula is a really,
I should've put a picture of it.
And it's so interesting to see it from
the air.
It's,
it's,
uh,
a finger of land that goes out to the
sea.
Is that an interesting place?
Because,
um,
during the Second World War when we were
patrolling all along the coast for a
ship's coming across automation,
a lot of ship,
a lot of airplanes were lost in the boy
in the brooks peninsula because right at
that point there's a change in the
current and you get all,
so there's a north and south current
coming and they change seasonally and
right at that point you can get a,
I've talked to a pilot about this when I
was flying over it with him and he was
saying that he had actually seen what
looked like Niagara Falls coming up
because of the currents are clashing.
You get this water coming up rising out
of the ocean.
And,
and uh,
he said it was just like this wall of
water coming up and then crashing down
the other side in the atmosphere.
So these are the things that only pilot
see,
I guess,
but he said it exceedingly dangerous
area,
but it's,
it's uh,
again,
a very important area separating the
north and the south and the kinds of
animal migrations,
whales and so forth and see birds.
And then if you look at the top end,
there's the boys see mode and there's
sea mounts.
These mountains that rise up almost to
the ocean,
top of the ocean.
Um,
but in the case of Boise,
mounted comes within 75 feet of the
surface.
Now I have talked to people that have
gone out there and their cell phones,
big sailboats and scuba dived on that
seem odd.
It's filled with life.
It's absolutely filled with life.
And,
and so we have a whole series of these.
This is the only one that gets any
protection whatsoever from fishing as
far as I can tell.
And there's other things in the scone
olins and,
um,
rarity is very important.
We'll look in the estuaries.
Another one of these strange little
fish,
uh,
things that I won't go into the sponge
reefs and so forth.
So this is not just a big blend,
a body of light blue or anything like
that.
When you start looking at what's on the
bottom,
it needs protection.
The Sea otters coming back,
um,
and,
and they're part of the ecosystem.
Now.
Uh,
some first nations hate them because
they're taking moistures,
they're taking all sorts of creatures
that they want to harvest.
Uh,
the coral reefs.
I've mentioned way Hannah's,
uh,
which is land co managed between Parks
Canada and now a marine conservation
under area under the Marine Conservation
Act and the Haida people,
one of the most innovative systems of co
management anywhere in the world.
I mean this is fabulous and this is
going to mean a whole different approach
towards fisheries management in the area
towards,
uh,
how the Haida people perceive their
responsibilities and how the government
of Canada and the province of Canada
actually,
uh,
it's all done in a Cole management
basis.
This is one of the most exciting things
that you can possibly imagine.
And this is what the southern end can
see down that yellow tip,
the southern end,
which happens to be where the highest
recorded winds were ever recorded.
And it was off a test oil rig there in
the 1970s,
I think it was 200 kilometers and hour
or something like that.
So this is the kind of habitat that's up
there.
And you can see the animals that are
living there at the sea lions,
the beautiful area.
Um,
oops.
Cmon um,
above that rock fish,
those fish,
many of them are 70 years old.
And as some of my colleagues,
they want to protect them to say,
would you eat your grandparents because
they're delicious.
They're served on many menus and a not
very sustainably harvested.
And in fact,
before boys see mount,
while it was still under consideration,
that's just a,
uh,
a plot of the,
the depth contours and these currents
that circulate around on the boys seem
odd,
but fishermen were being told to go out
there and fish while they still could.
So even in the,
this is safe,
seven or eight years ago when it was
actively knowing that boise is going to
be handled,
there was boats going out there.
So now that problem is solved,
but there's all these other problems
along the coast.
Should you allow bullets to go out to
other seamounts triangle island?
Uh,
most amazing place.
the day I went out there and the pilot
said,
you were lucky,
you get one to two days a year when it
looks like this is not covered in rain
fog.
You can see the little blip on the top
of it.
That was a,
a light house.
They put the light house up in the,
uh,
in the club level.
So no,
the light house keepers could never see
it.
The weather was so bad there that
lighthouse keepers often would get no
food for two or three months at a time.
Um,
sadly,
some of the lighthouse keepers went
crazy out there as well.
And,
and there's only the base of the light
house,
uh,
left,
hurricane blew the Adelaide house itself
away.
Um,
and so they also,
one of the leading scientists that
studied,
it's a great place,
one of the great nesting areas for
certain,
um,
uh,
important seabirds.
And,
uh,
sadly one of the scientists fell off the
cliff and she died.
There's a wonderful book though that's
been written about triangle island,
uh,
with a lot of watercolors and so forth,
by an artist that went out at a later
time.
Um,
it's,
it's a very interesting spot.
Now,
what do you think those things are?
Uh,
innovation with ocean technology and
sovereignty issues such as signing onto
the law of the sea.
We never ratified the law of the seed,
for example.
I think it's time to revisit and
strengthen our commitment to the ocean.
I think we've made a start with the
oceans action plan,
but I think it's,
um,
we've got some good points and it's
faltering in some key areas and not
enough resources or even attention is
being given to do it.
Ask when the last time this was reviewed
in parliament,
for example,
the fisheries,
as far as I can see,
the committee that deals with fisheries
and oceans matters and the current
parliament is,
we pretty much dysfunctional,
certainly not dealing with the kinds of
questions that we're talking about here
tonight.
It will probably receive the report of
the Commissioner on the environment,
sustainable development.
An Mba's say,
thank you.
We probably won't be needing any serious
discussion of this longterm discussion
of this.
Thank you very much for your hard work.
And that's what things are degraded to
at various times.
Now we need much more than that.
Uh,
so in the work of Finn and with,
I hope your other colleagues around the
country that you will join the voices of
those who do speak,
I think responsibly and sensibly about
the,
and for the a boat and for the oceans,
but that you will take these kinds of
broader perspectives and keep those in
mind even as you focus very strongly on
underneath for going after the
individual species and looking at the
problems related to all of the fish that
are out in the ocean.
Because it's clear we're going to be
eating more varieties of them and we're
going to find some very scarce still in
the future.
So thank you very much for your
attention this evening.
[inaudible]
how'd your attention for a long time
tonight?
Uh,
so,
but you're welcome to ask questions if
you'd like to do that.
Right?
If you ask a question,
then I'll repeat it because then we can
capture it on video,
but he'd be more than pleased to take
questions.
So if anyone has one.
Oh yeah.
Just the general problem of
sustainability.
I don't know if anyone's heard of Donald
Wright's idea of a progress draw.
So like our ancestors killing two
minutes,
let's say over one is a good idea.
That's progress.
But once they could drive 200 off a
cliff and kill an entire herd and then
like he'll more herds until they,
all our ancestors in those areas would
starve to death because they'd kill all
minutes essentially.
Um,
that would be progress drop.
What a book from dawn [inaudible].
And I was wondering,
um,
if you guys have any thoughts about if
that applies,
if that's like an oversimplistic
generalization or if it fits it.
Is there anything that you do about it?
So the question is whether the idea of
progress trap is relevant to this issue
in a progress trapped is the expansion
of technology to harvest beyond
sustainable limits,
I guess.
Do you want to take that?
Sure,
sure.
Um,
well,
it,
it's part of a larger problem of traps
and progress traps is certainly one.
And we get caught in those traps because
something works well for us for at the
time hearing.
And Sonia was true in the fisheries
case.
And then when it doesn't work well,
we're still adhering to that approach.
So one of the things,
and this is one of the reasons why I
bring up the ecosystem work and so
forth,
we have to open our mind to alternative
possibilities.
And also there's another little phrase
that you is called the option for
closure.
Um,
Eh,
you know,
for example,
if you lay out all the different uses in
the ocean,
um,
and everybody's scrambling for space in
the ocean,
you know,
the fishermen don't want aquaculture
because they can't park their boats or
their nets are in the way,
whatever it happens to be.
The oil people want one thing.
The aquaculture is don't want to do old
people,
et cetera.
So you've got to have some rational case
for making choices,
but option for closure if you do it
well.
And zoning is one of the ways to do
that.
Um,
allows for more to go on,
but at a lower risk.
And what we're doing now I think is
moving back towards a sectoral approach
where it happens right now that the
sector happens to be oil and gas.
It could equally be some other sector,
the could be deep ocean mining for
example,
or shallow ocean mining.
Um,
and,
and so we have to have a more rational
basis and just following whatever we
think at the moment is the best know.
And,
uh,
so that's,
that's really dealing with the progress
trap.
Um,
I think there's also a kind of,
and maybe the company said,
but it kind of a conceptual trap
sometimes as well.
And our,
we,
we adhere to ideas and therefore wonder,
open our minds up,
but then something comes along.
It could be some terrible accident,
uh,
the classic cases,
the Exxon Valdez or something like that.
And suddenly,
Bang,
you're in a whole new environment of
thinking and you're not prepared for it.
You don't have solutions.
You don't have,
haven't thought your way through the
kind of knowledge basis you need.
And so that's another kind of trap that
we have to face because that's why I say
think about accidents.
Many of the changes in our society are
the result of accidents and something so
awful happens that we have to think of a
new way of doing things.
And so a lot of what I think of the
scientific community is dealing with in
the oceans right now is to say we've got
to prepare ourselves for a future that's
very uncertain and therefore we need to
have a lot of knowledge and we have to
ask a lot of what ifs so that we are
prepared to make um,
direction shifts as necessary in the
future.
Whether they're from climate change or
some horrible accident or just changing
priorities and society.
One of those priorities for sure is that
all those certification programs are
going to become the way we do business.
And those people who are not engaged in
that,
in the fisheries are going to learn the
hard way.
That's my prediction for five to 10
years.
What would be the negative consequences,
especially economic consequences,
the loss of jobs or those mysteries.
We'll let some of those fee.
The question is the negative potential
negative consequences of zoning?
Um,
yeah,
it's a good question.
Really good question.
Um,
well to start with it is if you impose
zoning,
it's almost certainly going to have a
lot of negative consequences.
One of which is people simply won't
accept it and therefore the illegal
activities will take a,
so the first thing about zoning is it's
gotta be done on a consultative and
collegial and some conclusions,
the wrong word,
collaborative way and bringing
stakeholders together.
That's essential.
Otherwise,
there's all sorts of ways around zoning.
Uh,
the second thing about zoning is,
um,
if there are economic trade offs,
one has to look at that carefully
because there may be ways to avoid them.
And if you don't look at the economics
carefully,
then you can do really dumb things with
economic zone.
The third thing is if you're going to
make an assertion like we have both made
tonight that we think Mbas,
which is a type of zoning can be helpful
in the overall issue of fisheries
management.
Eventually maybe we can get away with
saying that for a number of years,
maybe even decades.
Eventually we've got to show the
results.
So there to be a lot of monitoring and
so forth as well.
Otherwise,
it's your word against my word,
so to speak.
And so,
so those are some of the consequences on
the positive side.
If you do things right with zoning,
you can actually get added value.
You can have,
uh,
well give you an example.
There was a full page ad in the paper,
uh,
in and uh,
British Columbia,
I think it was probably a number of the
papers by a group of people in engaged
in marine tourism on the discovery,
uh,
Somme area,
which is up the coast a little ways.
And the point was in this case that they
feared a bunch of clear cutting there
was going to totally destroy or largely
destroyed the potential for tourism.
So,
um,
you zone that you don't let that happen
or do you just let it happen while
they've got the rights to clear cutting
and the people are saying,
well,
we're going to lose their livelihoods.
People aren't going to want to come up
and see clear cuts.
Uh,
so those are things that if you do get
together,
there's probably a good solution and
everybody gives at the end of the day.
But there's probably a solution.
It's the same as that example between
that I gave of the whales going and
avoiding that ship.
Legends for years there was resistance
again,
there's going to be shifts crashing into
each other and all sorts of things or it
won't work,
work perfectly.
So.
So,
and that was the zoning one.
so look for the positive side of it and
anticipate if there are negative things,
can they be addressed?
Yeah,
just from the point of view of an
organization like Finn,
I think,
uh,
I read that the eye you use,
um,
also engage in a lot of odious behaviors
that aren't necessarily related to what
you talked about tonight.
I,
you know,
human trafficking drugs now,
that sort of thing.
And I'm just wondering,
in order to help,
uh,
give the issue more political
prominence,
is there,
do you see linkages possible or possibly
between this issue and others that
people that other groups or other people
make,
you know,
sort of considered to be sort of trigger
ideas if you understand the question?
So,
so the question is,
given that there are illegal fishing
activities in that those illegal
activities spill into other domains of
the illegality light,
perhaps drug trafficking and human
trafficking,
are there ways of making political
capital out of those connections?
Um,
and it's interesting that the,
I,
you you,
and I think that's relatively new,
that people have been trying to make
those linkages even though we've known
that there are linkages.
Um,
I th I think,
uh,
the answer in quick answer is yes,
but it has to be done very carefully.
Um,
and it has to be done on the,
it has to be evidence based and it has
to be done not just at a kind of a
global thinking level or won't lead and
where it has to be God down a very
serious things.
To give you one example,
um,
in the 1980s,
the fisheries industry and south of
Thailand really went into decline and it
was fish docks if been over fishing and
all they could catch her jellyfish and
squid.
Um,
so,
and there's thousands of boats and so
many of them turned into predatory
action against the Vietnamese refugees
coming out of Vietnam.
And,
and it was a terrible situation,
really awful.
Um,
well one of the things that happened was
that,
uh,
Thailand,
which was very concerned and the rest of
the world was as well,
but tyler and decided that they would
take on the function of turning the,
this past industry into a processing
industry for the world's tuna and
successfully managed to build a whole
new industrial basis around taking
frozen tuna from everywhere in the
world.
So if you look at all your canned to
interview happened to eat tuna that
you'll find most of,
it's been that Camden and Thailand ever
since.
So it created a new industry as it at
least picked up some of the jobs and got
out of a lot of the illegal other
activities.
And including a lot of the illegal
fisheries activities because of the ties
were also going off into Indonesian
waters and elsewhere and just savaging,
uh,
this fish docks there in terms of stocks
and so forth.
So there,
there can be solutions to that.
I think the,
on this iau you thing it's a huge issue.
FAO has been very useful on it.
Um,
and a lot of countries are now buying in
very,
uh,
in a very good way including many
developing nations.
I think we're making progress on it,
but as a long way to go still.
And so anything that can link it to the
other illegal activities,
some of which are very audience to
countries,
um,
that would be helpful.
Uh,
aggressive activism like a sea shepherd
can be positive or do you think that
that's counter productive?
The question is whether aggressive
action like that of the sea shepherd can
be productive for with her overall.
That's counter row.
Well,
I have a personal view on this.
My personal view,
which is I think a agreed upon by at
least some of my colleagues,
not everybody is that we need a number
of different,
it is a war that's being fought and,
and sea shepherd is,
is fighting actively on some fronts
where others fear to go,
but we need people who are on the front,
whether it's Greenpeace,
whether it's a sea shepherd,
whether it's people who are milder and
their actions,
but still,
uh,
for example,
in the case of Sierra Club,
no taking a harder stance decided which
might include some actions that are not
very nice but not on the level of going
out and ramping ships or whatever that
of sea shepherd has been accused of.
Um,
I think that there's a wide spectrum of
things are needed,
some of which are on that far end.
And I'm not,
I don't want people to be injured in the
process,
but they're making a point in a dramatic
way that,
that others cannot make.
Um,
then there are the people that,
um,
that go out and there's lots of them go
out and make movies.
They go out and do active research with
money that's raised for their cause and
then the many of the NGO's fallenness
and,
and so they're not going that far,
but there's still,
there's still activist,
highly activists and they're going out
and they're looking at the problems
locally and internationally and so
forth.
And they're valuable.
There's people like myself that have
chosen to work closer to government.
But I mean,
I,
I'd like to believe that I understand
some things about science and I want to
see that translated into public policy.
If I ever went out and did something
like Seasha,
right,
I certainly wouldn't be welcome in some
of the circles that I traveled with,
with government people or whatever.
So you make choices.
And then there are scientists that
often,
um,
want to remain very close to their
science,
uh,
whatever it happens to be and would
prefer to bring that information freely
and well out to the public and so forth,
but not be the front liners themselves.
And,
and so,
and then there's others as well.
Um,
I also believe in the power of one,
you know,
individuals like the school teacher.
And the whales in Nova Scotia,
um,
that was just an ordinary school teacher
in a small rural school district who did
something that was really very,
very valuable at the time.
And we can find many other examples.
I could tell you dozens of stories.
There's people,
um,
an organization that deals with
fisheries management.
Um,
I'm a collective sort of basis and the
west coast of Vancouver Island.
And they stick their necks out.
They,
they work collectively between first
nations,
um,
and with governments,
federal,
provincial to support,
supported from a variety of different
sources.
And they manage a lot of species that
are not the big flashy salmon or so
forth,
but other things.
And they're making progress in setting
the basis for a new form of fisheries
management.
And,
and it's tough.
Let me tell you how tough it is because
I've looked at this organization quite
closely.
Uh,
and,
uh,
so we need people that are activists in
different ways.
Uh,
we need people that are educators.
We need researchers,
whole range.
So I,
I do think,
uh,
I must admit that I have a higher degree
of respect for Paul Watson than many
people might have.
I think he's,
he's shown us,
he,
Sean,
a lot of light into some very,
very dark corners.
Okay.
So I kind of have this legal and the
same question I'm interested in how we
could introduce this.
How can I extract something on a more
daily interaction that we have,
you know,
like choosing the better flavor or a,
are there any maybe way of like,
because with food on land,
like you know,
quality is an important aspect.
So you can,
I guess you could take an individual to
a farm showing the process of what I
think of choice is,
but how do you show something has this,
I mean we don't have the same connection
with the fish because we could.
Sure.
So is there another way of educating and
what genuinely the public
wasn't?
He picked the first try,
you know,
you're,
you're a person who deals with
behavioral psychology sorts of things.
I think,
which of this is all about psychology
and behavior has been,
well the question is consumerism.
What can you know what can be done to
link these issues to behavior on a,
at a local level,
um,
you don't have something.
Maybe if there's like a project that you
have or there already is circulating
that maybe we can take people.
Oh yeah,
he can be like,
because this is an intellectual talk how
let's say,
and I can't really voice this
information process adequately.
So maybe if I can point individually.
Well,
I,
the only,
the only real effective means of
changing individual behavior that I
think would actually work is for people
to write their nps and the members of
the cabinet.
Because believe it or not,
politicians actually pay attention to
letters.
And so a lot of what we've talked about
tonight,
especially the marine protected areas
issue isn't going to be moved forward
unless the politician sense that there's
actual public demand,
like the frameworks already there,
right?
They've signed the treaties and so on.
But the way they're reading the
population is,
it's perfectly okay to ignore that.
And the only way to change that as far
as I can tell is to indicate that it's
actually not okay to ignore it because
right now it is okay.
And,
and that's not good.
Our political system actually does work.
It's much more permeable than people
really think because in some ways it's
left to its own devices.
You know,
most people don't really participate in
the political system,
so it leaves it in the hands of the very
small minority who do,
but it's surprisingly permeable if
you're interested in permeating it.
And so while that's,
that's my take,
at least at the political level,
that's one.
Uh,
let,
let me give you four or five things that
I think are really useful.
Uh,
one is,
uh,
if you have the trust in them,
these seafood guides are very helpful
and so you can use those in your own
personal life.
And if you go into a restaurant,
uh,
ask them has this,
and if you happen to enjoy fish,
ask them,
tell me about this fish.
What is a species?
Where was it captured from?
Um,
what is it certified fish that you're
serving?
Ask the chef to come out and talk to
you.
I've done that.
And,
and,
and go in if you use an ipad or an
iphone and challenge them on some things
when they say they don't know,
they,
there's no information.
And then I did this once in a very
respectable restaurant in Vancouver and
I warned them,
I said,
look,
I'm bringing a group of people who are
leaders in this whole seafood process.
They're going to have all sorts of
questions.
So I brought my ipad was brand new in
those days and did this come out six
months before and we sat down and half
an hour by the time that the poor chefs
were sweating and let me tie,
but they answered all the questions
correctly.
We got all information and we got past
all these fancy names and so forth.
So that's what another way in dealing
with the food industry do it at a
supermarket.
If you're not getting good answers right
to the president of the company and say,
you know,
I was in whatever chain had happened to
be local or national and,
and I could not get any answer above
whether the crowd that you're serving
with sustainably produced.
Can you tell me?
And if they can't go after them and say,
please,
I really want to,
not an honest answer,
but I'll bet you the answer and you'll
make your decisions.
And a third way is,
as you say,
go to the politicians and keep going to
the politicians.
Find out who the politicians locally
are,
the really have an interest in the
subject because there are little
clusters of people that don't get very
much support in both the Senate and in
the house.
There really are interested in they
cross party lines and some of these
things as well.
Um,
and so that's another way of doing it.
But go to this.
I think that unsustainable development
in general,
we have to go to the cities and what's
anything but Toronto and political
system right now and how much this would
come up to the top.
But I know certainly in the West Coast
and uh,
I think a lot of places in the east
coast,
it's very central.
People will talk about it to you and
they are the places where action is
taking,
taking on interesting approaches.
Uh,
the next one is to figure out,
and you can only do this yourself by
looking at different organizations,
decide which organizations you're going
to support and support them in ways,
not just maybe giving them some money
from time to time,
but ask how you can help because,
uh,
it,
just to give you a couple of examples,
world wildlife fund,
a Canadian parks and wilderness society
both have excellent,
excellent people that need support,
you know,
and not just money,
but they need people behind them in
various ways.
And there's various things.
Uh,
and I guess finally if you have children
will have children or whatever,
work with kids.
Kids genuinely want to do things better.
They understand kids,
you know,
you're cute animal.
Well I was a bit insulted about that
fish that your child.
But I thought it was kind cute myself
but,
but uh,
uh,
the important point is that kids love
whales are our little granddaughter
who's eight years old.
And she proudly announces,
oh I'm doing a research project on a
Pacific Dolphin.
And,
and by the time she finished that thing,
she knew a lot about Pacific dolphins
help people that way,
you know,
get at young people,
young people who really want to because
they are upset by these things and they
see it.
There's a lot of stuff on television and
so forth.
The Internet and they are getting done
that there's a problem and they happened
to love these things.
They love dolphins,
they love seals and they decided the
other certainly whales and uh,
they can't understand why these things
are in trouble or the fish that they
might eat her in trouble.
So those are some concrete ways that you
can actually address this and keep that
list in mind as you move ahead with Finn
as well.
Cause I think it's a really important
question when I'm talking and we all are
talking that may maybe a bit abstract
they hear,
but in each case,
you can bring these things down to,
uh,
to real life.
Another one on the west coast,
just to give you a nonstop on this.
But if you go to any school around
Victoria,
Greater Victoria,
you'll see salmon images,
uh,
that the kids have individually made and
painted and they're on the school
fences.
It's in front of them,
you know,
about sustainable and,
and,
uh,
some,
communities,
uh,
spray painting around,
sorry,
spray painting around gutters and
saying,
you know,
this water needs to assignment stream.
Yeah.
Self awareness.
All right.
So I think we've had your attention long
enough.
Thank you very much for coming.
[inaudible] much appreciated.
And thanks to Dr.
Hanson.
Thank you.
[inaudible].